I am devastated that I am too busy to be
a streamer I have told the story over
and over of Twitter and YouTube being
the foundation of the garyb brand which
is absolutely true that 2006 to 2010
moment was real I had forgotten that the
6 or nine months that I was really
flirting somewhat aggressively not as
consistent as Twitter and YouTube with
Ustream which in essence is twitch and
kick and Tik Tok live right now I forgot
how big that was I believe that if I had
time and wasn't actually running
businesses I would probably stream for
12 hours a day oh really I would and so
the other thing to think about is your
live strategy you know I think the
depths that come along with audience
engagement in live and streaming is
profound you're much more interactive no
longer are they consuming their they
feel like they're part of it it's more
social relationship you sound like also
you're making a big uh distinction
between live and vlogging right those
two SE vlogging is episodic no I'm
talking about streaming and live